well the General Secretary of the FDA
Union Dave Penman joins me live now Mr
Penman thank you so much for talking to
us so you are considering a national
ballot for industrial action are you
yes I mean what we would expect in
following uh the negotiations in health
and education was the start of a
negotiating process in the Civil Service
that's what we were promised by the
minister and it stayed in the space of
12 hours uh we've had a ticket or leave
it offered a four and a half percent put
to civil servants they just announced
that after telling us this morning in a
meeting that we did the courtesy details
in advance
um with no indication of any
um additional payment to cover the cost
of living Rises for last year which has
been a feature in both education and
health as you've seen there so several
servants once again getting
significantly poorer pay offer than
anybody else in the public sector
it's clear though this doesn't actually
affect senior civil service does it the
senior signal service
so the senior civil servants are covered
by a review body but the government has
made clear in the past including last
year that they would not want to see
Senior civil servants get paid raises
that went beyond what happened to those
below the senior civil service so it has
an impact on the senior Civil Service as
well as it essentially sets a bar
certainly that's how the government's
approached it
um in the past and set a second of going
rate for how things are going to be
dealt with but it's just extraordinary
events of the last 12 hours I mean we've
been waiting patiently having talked
about talks to suddenly have their rug
pooled from under our feet no enhanced
negotiations is what we were promised no
payment in compensation for the cost of
living over the last year where many of
these disputes have been about despite
that clearly being indicated in the past
and and uh quite frankly embarrassing
meeting with the minister today who had
no answers to the questions of why civil
servants have been treated so
significantly worse than the rest of the
public sector can you just tell us a bit
more um you did we meet with the
minister for the cabinet office this
morning as you've said why was that
embarrassing and what exactly was said
in that meeting
yeah it was with Jeremy Quinn I have
some sympathy for him I think these I I
suspect these are decisions that have
been taken elsewhere he's the one that
talked about trying to ensure that the
Civil Service wasn't the poor relation
of the public sector when we've met him
in the past or that's exactly what's
happened he could not answer why there's
no negotiations around this why the
promise of talks hasn't yet didn't even
begin and they're just publishing a a
perimet for the Civil Service and he
couldn't explain why civil servants are
are not receiving this sort of
non-consolidated one-off payment that is
applying elsewhere uh in the in the
public sector and in a city ham as a
government Minister he has an obligation
to his employees civil servants to
explain that to answer that why are you
treating them so different from
everywhere else in the public sector
that's for 2223 isn't it the one-off
payment if they had if they had said
okay listen we'll give you that one off
payment as I said with other sectors
would you have accepted that
I think that would have been the basis
for an agreement as you can see what
somebody else we know this is difficult
and members of the people who are
working and managing Public Services
even though there's a balance to be
struck between affordability and what
they get as a pay increase and that's
the sort of informal dialogue we've been
having I think that would have been the
basis for further talks which again is
what we've been promised as essentially
being no negotiations around
um this figure and what I think have
been the basis for the sort of dialogue
that takes place and each of the
employers to find a settlement I think
that would have been a much better place
to be and instead what he said to us as
a union that Prides itself on its
pragmatism and engagement uh with
government that there is nothing that's
valued about that that their only choice
is to consider industrial action and
there's nowhere to go in and that's just
an extraordinary place to put uh earn
members in but that's where we are and
that's that's what we're going to
consider our executive meets on
Wednesday I feel confident about the
decision they'll take about a national
ballot but once they have we will be
announcing what that means about a
ballot process and strike action among
some of the most senior public servants
in the country so do you think that that
is actually what's going to happen that
eventually we will see your members
striking
that there is huge anger out there about
what's happened in the impact of coastal
living regardless how much you earn uh
when inflation is at 10 and you had a
pay rise last year of below three
percent you feel the impact of that and
we've been telling our members the
engagement and negotiation is a solution
to this that's what ministers have been
telling us that's the approach we always
take to these issues let's negotiate sit
down in the table let's deal with
evidence we submitted independent
research about the impact on the economy
or of P Rises we wanted to engage in
find a pragmatic solution and that
essentially has been thrown in our face
this morning we have literally had 12
hours over this issue about uh 20 23 24
P where we had one meeting with
officials which was meaningless
yesterday and we'd have meeting the
brother Minister this morning where they
told us it was take it or leave it
um and so I have no doubt that palpable
anger that we've been seeing amongst our
members will translate itself into a
ballot for industrial action and just
finally what what your response when
it's when they're dealing with business
afford it and their main target the main
thing that they're trying to do is fight
inflation and once they do that it will
sort all the other issues out in the
economy
well we've demonstrated because we
provided evidence to the minister when
he asked us an independent report that
demonstrated that below inflation pay
increase he's let's face it these are
below inflation pay increases there's
another 35 claim as we're seeing uh
elsewhere has no impact on inflation and
government has to explain why is it
treating one bit of the public sector uh
worse than the other why is it an
education there's a thousand pounds paid
to compensate for the cost of living
last year and health is an extra two
percent plus sixteen hundred pounds one
or one off payment yet in the civil
servant that Civil Service there isn't a
single penny why is it that the civil
service is treated worse once again than
the rest of the public sector that's
what ministers have to answer and and
the minister this morning simply could
not answer that question okay Mr
permanent thank you so much for talking
to us